I want you to answer in six seconds cuz
that's how long the vine is go ahead
what do you have that makes companies
think you can sell for them great
content that's quality clean and
energetic boom that was like four that
was pretty quick that's really quick but
define that for ya now you get to have a
lot of substance you rip in your pants
off in a grocery store brands like click
on but why yes something about the pants
ripping brands like this kid can sell no
I think it's the fact that my content is
that the production quality is its top
notch on vine it's more than just your 6
second video my videos have layers
so it's pranks for example ripping my
pants off there's stuff that goes beyond
people think oh what happened before
this man what happened after cuz you see
the six-second I'm gonna guess your
pants were on before the vine no no so
yeah I know my pants are always out
before the vines I rip them off and then
clearly everyone's like what's wrong on
that that was a hard thing you just said
you didn't show the shot and then jumped
in doesn't sort of have to ask have you
have you hurt yourself doing any of this
stuff
unfortunately yes the answers yet I
would have imagined yes it's jackass
your inspiration no um just cuz I want
to put a little more humor than just
hurting myself yeah these are Liz some
pretty crazy clips you know I do I'm a
funny guy outside of just hurting myself
I like to think anyways were you a
dancer to start with no everyone asked
me that they asked me if I'm a
cheerleader or a gymnast no I'm just
really flexible I started stretching one
day and one day I was able to do the
splits all right well you did a vine
actually while you were here the bird
world headquarters say I just want to
get a sense for because we talked to
advertising gurus all the time about the
content they create the value around it
you sat in our studio for 30 minutes you
created something I want to see it I
want I could I don't know if I'm buying
of course
Hey
Oh oh my god that also looks like it
really hurts um yeah I think the jeans
made harder definitely
and then the boots all right can I ask
you are you making a fool of these
companies that are signing with you if
I'm a big-time CEO right and I said this
is what I need this what I need from our
company part of me feels like that CEO
feels like a jackass buying into yeah so
the clips are you guys saw they are a
little jackass see but a lot of my
videos are just slapstick humor where
people can enjoy them without laughing
at me and I think cuz my demographic is
younger and I know how to capture them I
know how to captivate and how to make
people laugh especially the younger
generation and I think brands now that's
what they're trying to do well they're
definitely trying to do they've been
trying to do it for years does it does
it does it surprise maybe or even amaze
you that they have so much trouble
reaching that audience it does because
to me it's so easy I mean like I am my
own demographic I think that's a secret
to my successes cuz I know what's funny
I know I'll make a vine sometime spend
hours doing I'll look at it but if it
sucks like I'll say it to myself just
because I don't want to trick myself how
long does it take to make the typical
vine it's ten minutes to three hours for
six seconds so a lot of people don't
expect that well three hours for six
seconds sounds like a lot but think of
what goes into a GM come here exactly
months yeah in months and millions of
dollars and yet as we all know that the
most uncock commercials are the single
most uncreated thing on television they
continue to pour stuff like money into
dollars yeah drop out of school to do
this full-time that's the hot topic
right now well answer it
whoa look at that yeah it's crazy next
subject are you gonna drop out of school
why not the only dilemma I have it
I don't know if this is sustainable
right now it is but is fine gonna die
is it gonna succeed who knows and then
what do you think your migration
platform couldn't you that's what we're
trying to do expand outsider to where do
you want to go I want to go mainstream I
want to act what is misdirect dot what
do you like I don't even know what
mainstream right right today TV movies
anything outside of strictly social
media I think do you how you said we do
you have a whole team we got yeah the
Logan Paul team I know they all at your
universe all this happen do you consider
this 15 minutes of fame or do you think
I want to take this everything explain
to me how you define this business so
yeah fortunately I I don't think it's 15
minutes of fame because my fans have
come to love my personality I have I
love them thank you
my engagement like on all my social
media is is awesome because I've people
who who love me more than just like oh
there's logan paul acting in a movie or
there's logan paul on instagram they
fall in love with my personality so I
got these cleaners it's it's beautiful
I could see why you want to do something
that lasts longer than six seconds but
why go for old media TV or movies for
example like isn't a platform like I
don't know maybe it's not Facebook but
something else supposed to be the future
supposed to be what is movies and yeah
it's just television you would think I
just think it goes back to the whole
sustainable thing um funny
this one is one look banana the banana
got your back foot father jump over a
car then the boom um yeah I think it
goes back to the whole sustainable thing
I'm not sure if the social media is
sustainable but movies television it is
to me it is all right do you run a risk
here that vine does go away that fast
forward seven years this was a flash in
the pan and you kind of look like a fool
what if seven years from now you decide
to pursue an engineering career and
these videos live on forever
then what have you thought of what those
consequences could be you know I think
what's his name the movies that Snoop
Dogg was a who Joe Francis
gone wild I think people who thought
girls gone wild great time let's be part
of it
those people kids wait angry yeah no
it's our conversation they probably are
all the time big mistake um honestly I'm
not too worried about that I'm the kind
of person where if I put my mind to
something it's gonna happen so if I want
to pursue this I'll make it happen all
right well your parent parent at this
point they could say this is great he
has all these followers when you first
started doing this given what a smart
kid you are you got into engineering
school did they think this was a good
move they didn't think it was a bad move
they're just kind of neutral about it
Logan you have 40,000 followers okay hey
a million they're like wow so this is
kind of serious working with big brands
you know Pepsi HBO and so they kind of
hopped on the train they actually each
have their own vine account and how
lucrative business for you pretty
lucrative for a college student I don't
want to say exactly how lucrative but
like I said for a college student we can
get our hands on anything in fact that
I'm working with the biggest brands in
the world is incredible how did they
find you having HBO and Pepsi find you I
think it's cause like I said they're
trying to reach a younger demographic
they're trying to expand into places
where they haven't hit yet and vine is
so new and so prime for those kind of
advertisements and promotions they go on
they say Oh who's popping on this media
they find me in boom brother